bear up ahead
let's see if we can find another way
around
wait did you say bear yeah what do we do
with that oh I gotta get on my horse is
a bear
what are we gonna do about the bear
aim weapon RT
all right I guess we won't shoot it
could be cocaine bear it looks like okay
bear look how big it is
actually in the in the trailer for
cocaine bear the cocaine bear doesn't
look big he doesn't you look kind of
scary well he's a CGI no yeah I
understand this but like it I think they
realize they can't make the cocaine bear
fat because then
because then he would be lazy yeah it
would be slow moving you have to have
like a
skinny agile there yeah like just woke
up from hibernation yeah took some
cocaine
exit Okay and she's going nuts
I really want to see that movie just to
see like how far they take it like how
can you have a movie for two hours on a
premise that feels like it should not
last longer it feels like a joke that
you
amongst friends for like 10 minutes and
like maximum 10 minutes like you have
like this weird banter about it and it
gets weird after like three minutes
so literally
but but this is based on a true story
right
so literally
it is it is there was some cocaine in
the woods dropped off in the woods right
so they're gonna do that and they're
gonna say oh it looks like some bear ate
into it okay that takes like two minutes
to introduce
maybe half the movie is just like the
cocaine story
yeah it could be that ain't normally the
case
or maybe like looking at how the cocaine
changes the relationship the bear has
with his family
and other Bears going like The Lion King
way yeah I don't know
it's a very silly movie
it could be like a cool action film
maybe they're going like I think they
might be hilarious kills a bunch of like
the bear kills a bunch of people I
almost hope that it's really dumb
because I think it would be funnier that
way I hope Liam Nielsen isn't
he made a job mistake you're stealing my
daughter that would be great he would
call the bear is that the guy from Taken
yeah taken yeah yeah it's I am a sucker
for those movies
taking all of them he's he's in a bunch
of he plays the same exact guy and he is
such a badass those movies freaked me
out
I think it was probably a good thing
I'd love to talk to our podcast he's a
really really interesting dude and he
like
same with uh what's the guy from
Breaking Bad
things that's a blonde guy the older guy
I don't know what his name is he Brian
Cranston I want to say he's like a
badass in real life too like I like it
when you're like
when you don't just play the part like
it's part of who you are well I feel
like playing the part
made him more of a badass and he
embraced it the part changed him and
that's really cool I mean when you play
a meth dealer
for like 10 seasons whatever it is it's
gonna change you